This video
has been sponsored by Honkai Impact 3rd.
If your family was killed
by horrifying goblins, what would you do?
They took everything from you,
and now they're about to destroy everything.
You love again unless you stop them.
I'm going to break down the mistakes made,
what you should do and how to be
to the goblins and goblin slayer.
This priestess girl signs up to become a new
adventurer, right as she meets this group
of young explorers who are also looking for
another member to add to their party.
And this guy tells Priestess Girl
that they're about to go on a hunt
for goblins
who've kidnaped some girls from the town.
Only one tiny problem.
They're all porcelain ranked, which is
the lowest rank that an adventurer can be.
And this reception girl knows
they're about to get slaughtered by the ever
eager priestess Girl accepts their invitation
and the hunt begins the gang enters
this eerie cave and Priestess Girl
begins to get too scared for her own good.
And this guy reassures her
that goblins are nothing to be afraid of.
And he knocks his sword
on the roof of the cave.
And our priestess girl even finds out
that this gang lacked the money
to buy any extra equipment
before they agree to go on this quest.
Meaning they're going on a hunt
without any extra gear. Right.
As she hears and sees a horde of terrifying
goblins jump out from behind them.
Oh, these guys failed so spectacularly.
It's disgusting.
And it was obvious from the get go
that they came into this
with their hopes and dreams leading them
rather than practicality.
And this will get them killed.
The problem
is this that in spite of their notorious
reputation, most people think of goblins
as insignificant pests
that can be easily dealt with.
But this couldn't be further from the truth.
But let's say we take the goblins
out of the equation completely.
This group started off on the wrong foot.
It was beyond apparent once
that dude bumped his sword on the ceiling.
Of that cave entrance,
and that was no coincidence.
The weapon he appears to be using
is a long sword
and was characterized as having a cruciform
hilt with a grip for two handed use.
And it was characterized not so much
by the longer blade, but by the longer grip,
and it was more prominently used as a weapon
for mounted or fully armored knights
as in people fully suited up, meant
to be fighting and wide open fields.
This idiot, I mean kid, he failed his group.
He did not take into account
his surroundings.
His group is going into a cave
where the tunnels
are not always going to be big enough
for him to use a two handed weapon.
The chances of him not being able to use
his full skill set with a two handed weapon
go way up, the chances of his sword
getting stuck go way up.
This kid is an idiot.
He should have picked a much shorter sword.
They failed to plan for this Goblin Quest.
They did not get to know their enemy
to the point where they clearly knew
that going too far deep into the caves
where the goblins have home
field advantage is a bad idea.
They should have stayed
closer to the surface near the entrance
and lure the goblins out one by one.
They should have used other means, such
as smoking them out because the goblins have
the nasty habit of attacking in great numbers
and it's going to cost them big.
The terrifying goblin
start attacking the gang in a frenzy right
as this wizard chick starts blasting spells
only to get overrun by the goblins
and stabbed. Good.
And this dude is even more useless
than we thought.
Taking pot shots until he fumbles his sword
and gets brutally killed with
this other chick faring even worse
and gets preyed upon by a goblin.
It's a horrifying sight and all hope is lost
when suddenly Priestess Girl
and the goblins hear incoming
footsteps of something or someone
revealing himself to be the silver
ranked adventurer Goblin Slayer.
Himself, and he orders Priest Girl to use her
holy light before he messes everyone
up, killing goblins
more efficiently than a suit.
Tor and Peter Parker burning this cave
and killing the Shaman Goblin leader himself,
eventually saving this one adventure
a girl and even killing the baby goblins
of this horrifying nest showing us
just how merciless this guy really is.
Goblin Slayer then even mentions
that goblins should never be underestimated,
especially ones being led by a shaman
like this guy or by a goblin lord.
The next day, Priestess Girl
meets Goblin Slayer again at the town center
and they get their next quest
involving goblins, of course,
and might as well as countless adventurers
disregard goblins,
thinking them to be nothing more
but a pest problem.
A quest only meant for beginners
and amateurs.
Later on, Goblin Slayer and Priestess Girl
reach the next goblin nest, a sinister
looking, ingrown tree trunk housing goblins
within and Priestess Go ready some fire
arrows for her silver ranked superior
and he fires them with everything he's got,
causing a massive fire
to search from within the Goblin base.
And he suddenly orders Priestess Girl
to cast a spell to trap all the goblins
inside the nest, burning them alive.
This shark's priestess girl who sees
how automatic and emotionless goblin slayer
is to all of this,
telling her to keep her guard in case any of
these goblins managed to escape somehow
no goblin is to remain alive.
Okay.
This priestess girl needs to stop feeling
sorry for nature's worst mistake.
Goblins like to dwell on frontier lands
untouched by military forces,
and they have the tendency to prey
on small villages and raise terror on folks
that cannot defend themselves.
And because the goblin species
is an entirely male group.
Tell me, how do you think they get down
to the business of being able to reproduce?
Huh? That's right.
Which is why some of the greatest crimes
from goblins can range from serial mass
breeding with the females of other species
to mass murder.
Even leaving a single child
goblin alive can come back to bite you
because these vindictive
little bastards like to hold grudges
and can rapidly grow into adult states,
which can make them into an enemy
that you would never want to mess with.
The thing that makes this breed
so treacherous
is that they always hunt in mass numbers
despite their inability to be super smart.
They aren't
dumb asses either, and will eventually learn
whatever it is that you throw at them.
Which is why maintaining a distance
and striking first
and heart with no mercy is the best strategy
that this group could have planned for.
What I would worry about in the future
would be in regards to Priestess Girl
and her ability
to maintain a high level of endurance
when it comes to casting and retaining
the presence of spells by sheer will.
Because from the looks of things here,
it seems as though
she hesitated when ordered by Goblin Slayer
to cast that spell, and it's obvious
that she lacks practical experience.
I would worry about how she'll handle things
next time her adrenaline spikes
and were in critical danger.
I would make her practice
all her spells in her arsenal till she pukes
the moment we got back to the village.
Because while we might be with the Goblin
expert, their ability to overwhelm us
by sheer numbers cannot be ignored.
Which means the next time we're out,
Priestess
Girl must not choke under the pressure,
but you know it won't cost them their lives.
While out on the hunt,
The dawn of a new day arrives
and in comes a party of three featuring
this off girl who will call Legolas
Chick or Orlando Bloom for short.
I'm kidding.
Legolas Chick then tells the receptionist
that she's looking for a famous adventurer
named Orcbolg.
The receptionist has no idea
what the hell she's talking about,
and neither does
she know what a dwarf guy over here
is talking about either.
Just then, Lizard Guy mentions
that they're looking for
the one known as Goblin Slayer, right
as he appears from behind them.
They then tell him that they have
a new mission request for the man himself.
In this conference room.
They mentioned that due
to a growing number of demons in the capital,
thanks to the resurrection
of a famous demon king,
a horrifying battle will soon take place
between them and the rest of the world.
But while the elves
and the rest of the world's species
prepare for this great battle and increasing
number of goblins have started becoming more
and more active everywhere,
making the preparations
for this battle
against the demons impossible.
However, this group of adventurers have found
one active goblins nest responsible
for all of this, which is why they need
someone who knows goblins.
And so Goblin Slayer accepts the job,
not knowing that this time around
it'll cost him everything he has,
including the lives of his pals.
If he's not careful enough.
Later on in the night,
the adventurers
share a meal with each other and begin
familiarizing themselves with one another.
All of their strengths and weaknesses.
Okay, hold up.
We need to talk about
the additional members of our party,
because unlike the first Goblin hunting group
that we met that got obliterated
by goblins this time around, we seem to have
some real potential within this group.
Lizard Guy is a cleric,
which means he can use magic
along with conventional weaponry
and can cast up to four spells a day
with the spells
ranging from summoning warriors
from the undead to making weapons appear
out of thin air, performing healing spells,
using magic to increase his own strength
and possesses the ability to rust
any equipment rapidly and can even produce
the sound of a dragon's mighty roar.
But the thing about this character
is that we finally have a powerful partner
that can aid us in performing brute
force attacks in the form
of getting up close to goblins.
And unlike Priestess Girl,
this guy doesn't need to rely on his magic
in order to kick some serious ass Legolas
chick is another serious addition
to our squad
because she's an elf
she's over 2000 years old,
and she knows how to use a bow and arrow,
which means we now have the ability
of ranged attacks against the goblins
because unlike Goblin Slayers,
ranged attacks, this elf has the ability
to fire arrows in curved paths.
She can change the trajectory of her arrows,
and she can fire multiple arrows
simultaneously.
With extreme proficiency.
Now, Dwarf Guy is a shaman, which means
he can also aid us in casting spells
up to for a day.
Those abilities do require a catalyst
in order to function, such as casting
one into the air in a fine mist, enough
to cause anyone who breathes it in to become
incredibly drunk and nonfunctioning.
And because of this
he also has a bag of spells up his sleeve.
This group provides us
with a range of possibilities
with how we'll be able to tackle the goblins
from relying on Priestess Girl to provide us
with healing and shielding cover
to using Lizard Guy as backup.
If we need to defeat the goblins quickly
and with brute force along with using Legolas
check
to provide us with tactical ranged cover
thanks to her ability
to control the trajectory of her arrows
and hell, even dwarf guy with his clumsy
spell casting will still prove to be useful
since we can use his odd spells
as method of distractions against the goblins
in case we ever need to surprise them
from behind.
Needless to say,
we've got some talent this time.
In this goblin hunting roster,
the burgeoning blossom of a new day begins
and the sun ascends over this goblin
nest entrance just as these vicious monsters
get shot down by Legolas chick
emptying the area of the monsters
and the group of adventurers prepare to enter
what might as well be goblin hell itself.
Slowly but surely the group combs
through the corridors of these sinister
looking catacomb
like structures right before Legolas check
spots a trap right in front of the group.
But Goblin Slayer notes that this is strange,
since unlike before,
there are no totems in sight, meaning there's
no shaman around, and ordinary goblins
would never be able to set traps
This means there's something much
more sinister leading the goblins down here.
Little
do they realize just how right they are.
Dwarf Guy then recognizes the tracks
as the group prepares
to take down the horrors that await them
and they enter an atrium like room holding
dozens of sleeping goblins.
But this goblin slayer is one crafty
son of a gun and prepares the group
with his plan of attack,
starting with Dwarf Guy and Priestess Girl,
combining their spells to create a sleeping
spell more powerful than even two down
two bottles of tequila, allowing the gang
to put these goblins to sleep for good.
However, suddenly
the gang feels a blasting wind erupt
from a dark entrance way, forcing the group
to take notice of the impending bellowing
footsteps, approaching them fast.
It's something big and something
far more powerful and bigger than any goblin
anyone has ever slayed before.
It's an ogre.
Okay, this group is royally screwed.
Aside from his massive structure
and brute strength, this guy can regenerate
minor wounds inflicted upon him by swords
and other sharp weapons and has the ability
to cast a massive fireball.
And this means that one spell
casting from him and word dead,
which means
we need to take out his ranged attack
first and foremost, or more specifically,
the method
by which he summons his spell, i.e.
his mouth.
If I'm Goblin Slayer,
I need to use the entirety of my group's
strength in order to pull this off.
Option one The entire group attacks
and distracts the ogre, while Legolas trick
fires fire arrows into the eyes
and mouth of the ogre, ideally blinding him
and severely burning the inside of his mouth
and esophagus.
I would then have the group retreat
and utilized ranged attacks before going into
close quarter combat to take the ogre down.
Option two I would have dwarf
guys summon a fierce spell, which is a spell
used to control a goblins emotions.
However, in this instance,
I would order him to use the spell
to call out a swarm of locusts
to distract the ogre as he has done this
before with this spell in the past.
This in of itself won't stop the ogre,
but it would buy us enough time
to not get wrecked by the ogres.
Fireball time
in which I would order Priestess
Girl to use her spell of purification,
which is a spell to remove the impurities
from people and items.
This, when performed on a living being,
could in theory turn their blood into water.
And I'm pretty darn
sure that an ogre's blood is not that clean,
which would in turn kill the ogre.
Now, this last part is highly risky,
which is why beforehand
I would have Priestess Girl
try out as many different ways
that she can utilize her spells,
because if she screws up on this planet,
then we're all dead.
If I was Goblin Slayer, a contingency plan
that I would have encased Priestess Girl
didn't have the balls
or the skills to be able to go through
it would be to make use of lizard guys
partial dragon spell,
which would enhance his strength and speed
greatly and I would have Goblin Slayer
personally down a bottle of stamina potion
which the group does carry.
I would then utilize both his and lizard
guys attacks to come
with the ogre in an omnidirectional fashion
and simply cut him down where he stands
since we'd both be effectively
on magical steroids,
all the while having synchronized attacks
from the rest of the group.
This horrifying ogre isn't playing games
and creates this giant pulsating fireball
right at the same time, Priestess Girl
conjures up a magic wall protecting the gang.
But the spell from the ogre
exhausts Priestess Girl fast,
allowing him to land a blow to Goblin Slayers
face in an instant, knocking him down hard,
forcing Priestess Girl to tend to his aid,
granting him the quick strength to whip out
one of his scrolls
right before this ogre prepares
to obliterate him with another fireball
until suddenly Goblin Slayer cuts him down
with a magical gate,
scrolling to the bottom of the sea,
unleashing the menacing pressure
of the deepest parts of the ocean, causing
the water to unleash at a terrifying speed
and tear this ogre apart,
taking out one more ungodly creature
from this earth later on elsewhere, deep
beneath the town's sewers.
These two rookie adventurers
try fighting these ginormous terrifying rats.
But this dude gets his sword stuck
within the corpse of one of the rats.
And this other wizard girl isn't of much help
forcing them to abandon the quest entirely,
which means no pay.
And they've just lost their own weapons.
And so flat broke.
They end up sulking all the way back to
the town center and decide to ask an expert
for their help on how to slay the menacing,
overgrown rats hiding beneath the sewers.
So they decide to ask Goblin
Slayer himself, who tells them to use a club
as they're easier to find for free.
And so now, loaded up on weaponry,
the duo heads back down into the depths
of the town's sewage system and run
right back into these unstoppable rats.
However, this time beating these things
isn't the main concern, as they just have run
into an army of disgusting
Godzilla like cockroaches, forcing them
to run for their sweet lives by the OC.
This is the absolute stanky situation
I would never want to be in.
And worst of all, we've just crossed paths
with nature's nastiest little villain,
the cockroach.
Though at the very least in our world,
we don't have to go up against those steroid
abusing cockroaches from terra formers,
which means we still have a chance.
Now, we don't know what year
this takes place,
but it's clear from the decor
that we're definitely back in medieval times.
And if that's the case in those days,
let's just say the world hasn't worked out
the cleanest way to treat their sewage waste
with some parts of sewage tunnels back then,
even containing enough methane and chlorine
from buildup up of waste
to be highly flammable and incredibly toxic.
Though from the looks of that lit candle,
it makes me think that the concentration
level of gas presented down in those
tunnels is not high enough yet,
at least for us to use to our advantage.
And those stupid kids, of course, came down
into this hellhole completely unprepared,
which means I think we've got only
one more move in our pockets.
This girl is an apprentice cleric,
which means she's
kind of like priestess girl,
but way less cool.
And as a result, she's only got one spell
a bolt of lightning that she can use.
But the thing is, she's just a rookie,
which means I would entrust her
with a ranged attack
if that attacker was two feet away from her
and so because of this, we really only have
one option,
which would be to make her shoot a massive
bolt of lightning up
towards the roof of that sewage system,
causing the entire thing to collapse,
separating us from those things completely.
Now, I know it's a gamble,
but it's safe to say that the sewage system
isn't up to code as once in the modern day.
And, well,
we really don't have many other options here.
So it's time to take some risks
using a combined method
of throwing the lit lantern
and using wizardry, the duo burn and stun
the cockroach is enough to knock them
on their backs
before slaughtering them, unknowingly
preparing them for an upcoming battle
that will test everything they have
along with the Goblin Slayer.
Soon enough.
Back at the town center, Goblin Slayer
finds a request from someone from a far
distant land that specifically asked for him,
someone and none other
than the Archbishop of the Supreme God,
the Sword Maiden herself a legendary
go to ranked adventurer who ten years ago
defeated the demon Lord herself.
So Goblin Slayer, along with his gang,
sets out for Watertown, an idyllic town
with a much more sinister problem
dwelling beneath the city's surface.
And to top off the bad news,
Legolas and Priestess Girl make Goblin Slayer
promise to not use any water torture
nor fire, nor poison against their soon
to be Goblin victims
just as the gang reaches the town.
And more specifically,
the Temple of law itself, where Swordsman
Domain tells the group of adventurers
that about a month ago,
an assistant of the temple
was brutally murdered late at night
while out on an errand with her corpse
sliced right open while she was still alive
and that attacks
on women and abductions on children
have begun to increase ever since then.
The sword made and then tells them
that they've discovered the culprit behind
all of this.
Not a man but a goblin.
And since this town was built
upon another town, there's no doubt
that where they're hiding is beneath
the town's surface, deep underground
and because of the demons
raiding the capital, the military is spread
too thin to help, which means it's up
to Goblin, Slayer and crew to take them out.
Supplied with an old map from Sword Maiden,
the gang plunges
deep beneath the Earth's surface
and sure enough to encounter
a horde of terrifying goblins
right from the get
go and quickly cut them up.
Just like a bad boy chef at Benihana.
But something is up as there's just
too many goblins to handle with this boat
charging down the sewer and full of flesh
hungry goblins coming right for this group's
throat, forcing the gang to work together.
Priestess Girl
then uses her spell as a shield,
just as Goblin Slayer
throws a blinding
smoke bomb right before him.
And the lizard guy rain hail
upon these green goblins dwarf guy here
then drops a giant rock on top of the boat,
sinking the ship along with the goblins
all the way down to the bottom
but they're not out of the woods yet
because just then
this horrifying
reptilian beast pops out of the water
and surprises the hell out of the group
forcing everybody to run.
Okay, we are in serious trouble here
because this swamp dragon doesn't look like
it's a vegan.
Now, realistically, this swamp dragon
is no different than a plain ol alligator,
which is why we could use what we know about
the sneaky swamp dwellers to our advantage.
Because face to face,
we can't really think about taking him
head on as its overwhelming structure
would likely be too much
for us to handle in the moment.
However, the one thing that we can take on
is its head, literally,
because the snout of an alligator
is covered in sensitive receptors
to make its snout and obviously eyes
the most vulnerable points on its body.
And this is where our little dwarf
friend can finally pull his weight
because he's exactly who we need
for this scenario.
Unfortunately,
though, casting spells takes a few seconds,
which means we'll need to give dwarf guys
some time enough
in which he'll be able to cast his spell.
Which is why I would order Lizard Guy
to throw a dwarf guy ahead of us as we run
like an American football,
which will clear Dwarf Gav the monster
and give him at least four
to 5 seconds of time
before we catch up to him again,
giving him enough time
within that time frame to conjure up a stone
blast spell, creating some rocks
and making them grow as big as hell
before firing them in rapid succession
towards the alligators, snout and eyes,
distracting him enough to wean him off of us
completely, or give us enough time
to get away from him within that hallway.
Because we don't need to defeat him.
We just need to get him off of our tail.
The group runs like mad, barely escaping
with their lives, but Goblin Slayer
has a trick up his sleeve, just as he spots
a goblin ship near them making Priestess Girl
whip up a magic light,
distracting the goblins long enough
until this swamp
dragon pops up and devours them whole.
But the horrors aren't over yet
because Goblin Slayer knows that goblins
don't know how to use boats, which means that
someone taught them this skill.
And if the goblins were here long,
they would have known about that swamp dragon
and wouldn't have dared using any boats,
which means someone or something
brought all those goblins here recently
and on purpose.
The next day the group heads back
deep underground to find the leader
behind all of these goblins.
And this time Goblin Slayer brings along
his newest pet a canary, a bird designed
to panic at even the slightest hint of poison
gas being used within the area.
Because these goblins seem more
than intelligent
enough to handle using such deadly tools
just then, they cautiously enter
a room where they find something horrifying
a prisoner chained down and unconscious.
But Goblin Slayer isn't fooled,
and it makes them realize that it's a setup
right before the door behind them
suddenly closes shut.
Poison gas
then begins flowing out from
within the walls of the room,
having the group cornered like rats.
Goblin Slayer
then hands the group a bit of charcoal
and tells them to wrap this in cloth
and around their face
as this will protect them from the poison
within the air.
He then demands that the group makes two bags
of quick lime
and volcanic earth together to form concrete
and to block the holes with.
But Goblin Slayer knows that it won't be long
before an army of goblins comes crashing
through those doors.
And he's right, because all of a sudden
a loud bang erupts just outside
and a horde of goblin beasts
try barging in through the door
and the group readies themselves
for the most brutal fight of their life.
But the news keeps on getting worse
because Legolas check it, then hears
the incoming footsteps of something
much larger in size
than the rest of the goblins.
Just then the biggest green beast
you've ever seen in your life
rips right through the door,
and its piercing mandibles crave human flesh.
It's a horrifying goblin champion
and the group prepares
for the most terrifying
fight of their entire lives.
Okay, this is insane.
This is a horrifying beast.
It's a goblin champion,
a variant of goblins considered to be a hero
among the Goblin race.
And it's much larger, both
in mass and equipment than regular goblins.
Now, while they may be capable fighters,
there is a way
that this group can take this goblin champion
head on, and that will be to fight dirty.
This is a battle between life and death,
and playing nice isn't going to give us
any extra chances at winning.
Here's how we're going to do this.
We're going to focus on two parts
of the Goblin Champion's body parts,
namely the Achilles tendon
and the pupil itself also.
Now, in basic anatomy,
the Achilles tendon is what pulls on the heel
and allows us to stand on our toes
when walking, running or jumping.
However,
if an Achilles tendon were to rupture
while the individual
would be still able to walk,
it would greatly reduce
that person's ability to be mobile.
Now, while the physiology of a goblin differs
than that of humans,
the way that gravity works on the goblins
joints I think it's actually very similar.
And it's a safe bet that if the group focuses
on slicing the area where
this Goblin's Achilles tendon would be,
this would greatly limit its ability to move.
Secondly, following the rupture of where
his Achilles tendon would be,
I would also slice
this Goblin's Popliteal fossa,
which is the area in the back of the knee,
an area
containing important nerves and vessels
passing from the thigh to the leg.
Like I said, if we cut the area
where this goblin's popliteal fossa would be,
even if he doesn't have one,
I'm pretty sure that thanks to Gravity,
this goblin would feel the sudden painful
weight of his entire body
and that a very large body
would come crashing down hard
because we literally just took out
two very important parts of his legs
that, you know, he kind of needs to stand on.
Utilizing what we know of basic anatomy.
This will allow us to at least immobilize
this Goblin champion
and possibly get it on the floor
this way, giving us the choice of either
running for our lives
or taking this Goblin champion down.
The gang puts on a courageous and desperate
fight against the goblins, but it's no use
cause this Goblin champion
is too horrifyingly awesome at what it does,
which is to kill awarding Goblin Slayer
with more than a few bloodied bruises
and sickening blows to Goblin Slayers, face
shocking Priestess Girl into accidentally
turning off her magik forcefield,
letting all the goblins in and allowing this
Goblin champion
to take a bite right out of her sweet flesh.
But shockingly out of nowhere, Goblin Slayer
surprisingly rises up and jumps right
on top of the Goblin Champion,
pouring every ounce of his remaining
well into his final act,
choking the shit out of the Goblin champion
with some human hair, eventually killing him
and sending the rest of the goblins away.
Scared shitless for their lives.
Thankfully, Priest, this girl and goblin
slayer managed to barely make it out alive.
The next day,
the gang thing goes to check on a
now rested goblin slayer
before the group recovers
from the trauma of that battle
and filled their bellies
with some food and get new equipment.
And the gang prepares themselves
to go down again into those horrifying sewers
because this time Lizard Guy tells the group
that he's found something within the sewers
even more menacing than a goblin champion
and something far more strange.
This creature of chaos,
using its AI to unleash the power
of disintegration, melting
anything that it looks at
in mere seconds, though it won't attack
unless provoked and won't attack them.
Unless they enter the room.
Okay, this guy is a whole new character,
and we don't know much about it,
but what we do know is what it's capable of.
Aside
from creating an extremely hot beam of energy
that can disintegrate anything in its path,
it can also dispel any active
spells made within its affective range,
meaning our spells are within
its range will not work.
However, like we just found out, it
won't attack us if we don't enter the room.
Now, in this instance,
I think the best thing we can do
is to use some good old fashioned
weaponry to take this beast out
since he'll be able to dispel any spell
we throw at him. But in this case,
I have to say, what's the rush?
The gang is acting like they're on the clock
when in reality
there's no need to rush at all.
No enemies are nearby as of yet,
which is why I argue that this group
should take their sweet time
in planning out their next move.
I'd even use this time to head back up to
the town surface to procure some explosives
from the town's armory, draping a sock over
set explosive and attaching a Fuze to it.
Now, if we had trouble
getting any such fumes around town,
then we could simply make our own
by pouring 36 grams of potassium nitrate,
along with 24 grams of plain
sugar into a cup, and thereby creating a 60
gram composition that is then to be shaken up
vigorously, mixing both particles together,
after which we would add
one third cup of water into a medium high
heat frying pan, quickly boiling the water
before adding the composition
into the mix as well, and making sure
to stir the mixture until it dissolves
completely before adding a batch of 100%
cotton yarn string into the pan,
making sure to let this string soak up
all the composition thoroughly
before laying it out to dry on a pan sheet,
speeding this process along by putting it in
an oven or whatever equivalent
that they have available
for about 20 minutes
before taking it out to cool for another ten.
Now with a slow burning fuze
that we have in spades, next
we'd simply need to form some axle grease
or rubber solution equivalent to whatever
they have
within that town to seal the sock with.
And they could even seal it off with hot wax.
And all of this is what it will essentially
create a makeshift sticky bomb from here.
I'd bring a whole carton of these bad boys
back down with me
and simply camp out and hurl these things
at this eyeball monster likely in quick
succession, ideally sticking our explosives
onto its sweet face and then going, boom.
Now, if that doesn't work
and we need a distraction
to keep its fiery gaze from melting us
as we throw our bombs that one of us
could simply run around the eyeball monster
in the other direction
while we throw our makeshift bombs
like a major league pro and voila,
eyeball monster is taken care of.
You're welcome.
The gang is at a loss for tactics
but Goblin Slayer has a trick up his sleeve
using Legolas check to distract the monster's
gaze.
Dwarf Guy comes from behind to use a sleeping
spell on this horrifying eyeball monster
giving Goblin Slayer
enough time to open up a big bag of flower
and throw it right into the air
right before Lizard Guy
summons a monster to head inside the room.
Ray alerting the now awakened eyeball monster
into unleashing his fire stare
until suddenly a massive explosion erupts,
lighting the whole room ablaze, forcing
Priestess Girl to shield off the room
for the group's protection
after the fireworks,
the gang counts their blessings
right before they realize
what this mirror really is.
It's a portal to an army of goblins.
This is how they arrived
into the underground sewers of the city.
But they don't have time to react
because just then, Legolas, check.
Here is a swarm of goblins
headed straight for them.
And so the gang
quickly sets up a defensive position
before they are attacked by more horrifying
goblins, including the same goblin champion
back from the dead.
This scares the shit out of everybody.
Lizard guy takes down the mirror
on the orders of Goblin Slayer,
and the group takes cover under it.
Preparing for Dwarf Guy and Priestess Girl's
massive spell blast, casting an eruption
across the entire underground base,
destroying the mirror
and killing every last goblin with it.
Later, Goblin Slayer confronts
Sword and Maiden herself and finds out
that she actually knew about the goblins
being underground. The whole time.
And she basically tells Goblin Slayer
that since she got violated by goblins
as a teenager,
she was too traumatized
to defeat them herself
and wanted the public to realize
just how awful goblins really are.
Oh, and she totally has a hardcore crush
on our boy, but he's too focused on goblins
to give a damn idiot.
The next day, the gang gets word that the
demon lord in the capital has been defeated.
However,
many of his armies still remain active,
including armies of goblins spread out across
the land that could show up at any minute.
Goblin Slayer later in the day
stumbles upon the most horrifying thing
something that will shock everyone
in this village to their core.
Hundreds of goblin footprints
just outside the village.
Goblin Slayer then runs home, back to where
he's been resting to tell these chicks
that he's been shacking up with in a very PG
sort of way to run
because these tracks of goblin footprints
are not like anything he's ever seen before.
And it suggests that this army of goblins
definitely has a leader, not a shaman
or a goblin champion.
But a goblin lord, and that the attack
will come tonight or tomorrow at dawn,
meaning any outside help from the military
won't be able to come in time,
which means that this village
is all that stands in its way,
and the village is entirely on its own.
The Goblin Slayer
then runs into the town's center
to warn
all the adventures
that goblins are about to attack this village
and that everybody should join
in on the fight. And he begs for their help.
Unfortunately for him, though,
everybody thinks he's a bona fide weirdo,
choosing to always be quiet and stoic
and to only take on Goblin job.
This is why they instead
resist his pleas for help, opting
to let him handle this mess alone instead.
Okay, this is a huge deal,
because if we thought Ogres and Goblin
Champions were a big deal enough,
then a Goblin Lord is beyond terrifying.
Because, unlike other goblins
who are for the most part, wild
and irrational beasts, a Goblin
Lord is the only known rational goblin
capable of leadership and plotting.
Unlike their brethren, they've evolved to be
capable of thought and high intelligence
and is a foe that we cannot take lightly.
They are master tacticians, expert,
swordsman, and excel in leadership positions,
which means if you take his skills combined
with the accelerated growth
that goblins naturally have,
this means that we have a massive
army of goblins headed by a military genius
more capable than most humans are.
While Goblin Slayer
spent years training to fight the goblins
he did and spend time learning
arguably one of the most important skills
that anyone could learn in life,
which is social skills being
charismatic around people, can be vital, too.
While some people don't think
that this will work,
however, being charismatic will draw people
to you like a magnet and make them more
willing to support you and your endeavors
all simply because they like you.
But right now, Goblin Slayer is looked up
as a non sociable weirdo
by everyone in this room,
which means for him,
we need to quickly act fast in order
to convince these folks
of our hiding debonair charm
because no one will want to help us
otherwise.
Now, while we can fix
others perceived impressions of us,
we can try the act of humility
and lessen ourselves
in front of everyone else.
Because so far,
everyone thinks that the reason
we only hunt goblins is that we think
we're too good for any other type of enemy.
And they don't even believe that we deserve
to be civil
ranked through Goblin slaying alone.
Which means the first thing
we need to correct
is this perceived image of ourselves
by addressing it head on.
I would start by addressing
and revealing the reason as to
why we've only been hunting goblins
all this, while telling the whole room
of our traumatic past involving goblins
and the death of our sister at the hands
of a goblin when we were a child.
I am pretty darn certain by showing
a little bit of humility and revealing the Y
as to how we came to be, that we will be able
to gain the sympathy of everyone here
and ideally gaining the respect
or pity in order to lend a helping hand.
Now, if this didn't work,
then I would also talk
to the receptionist girl
to see if she would be able
to create a makeshift quests for us,
offering up a reward to all those
who decide to battle the army of Goblins.
Because you've seen the way she's been
eyeing our goblin slayer
throughout the entire season,
we're pretty darn
sure that she will help him.
Suddenly this douche bag and red earrings
finally warms up to Goblin Slayers.
Please, at the town center, Adventuring Guild
also offers up a reward for the goblins
one gold for every goblin slain,
and this definitely gets everyone
else's mouth salivating at that thought
as the whole faction of adventurers
finally get in on the action.
Listening to goblins
slayers, plans of attack,
readying the group
for the most intense fight of their lives.
The Knight arrives and the goblins eerily
snake through the grasslands in the distance,
leaving human prisoners out in the open
field.
Firstly to lure in the humans,
forcing the adventurers
to quickly rescue the hostages right
before the army of goblins comes
in, charging in droves,
erupting into a majestic battle of attrition
with blood spilled left and right
as man and goblin
wrestle it out with their lives on the line.
Goblins riding on wolves and the world's
finest top adventurers duking it out
on the plain grasslands and elven arrows
perforate the air in the thousands,
causing more chaos to befall on this town
than anyone has ever experienced before.
Just then, a bunch of Goblin champions
come in, running
to test the utmost strength of the guilds
best silver ranked adventurers,
the surprising amount of resistance
and strength from within the town starts
to threaten the Goblin Lord,
who way back in the distance
begins to retreat,
knowing that if he can escape,
then the goblins will live another day.
But too bad for him.
Goblin Slayer already knows all of his moves,
and he greets him head on, ready
to kill him.
And Goblin Slayer walks up to the Goblin
Lord himself and the two engage in close
combat to the death.
The two of them charge at each other
joust style and swing blade for Blade
until our man critically injures the Goblin
Lord, pissing him off to the bone, unleashing
something within him that comes charging
right back at Goblin Slayer, slicing his arm
and knocking him down hard and the Goblin
Lord walks up to the slayer of goblins.
The Goblin Lord begins stabbing on our heroes
face like a game of dance dance revolution.
And He readies his
axe to kill the goblin slayer
until his body freezes up its priestess girl
and she cast a spell, trapping the Goblin
Lord within a magical wall
like structure, trapping him good.
The Goblin Lord uses his intelligence
and cunning ness to articulate in plain
English to please be spared.
However, this time
Priestess Girl isn't a pushover
and lets Goblin Slayer stab the Goblin
Lord in the face and our hero passes out.
But thankfully his balls are bigger
than those that watch our anime channel.
I'm kidding.
And He manages to get back up
and head back to the town center
to a cheering group of adventurers
who dine and drink
the night away, celebrating the town's safety
and the money that they've all just earned.
And they also celebrate the safe
return of the Goblin Slayer himself,
leaving yet another day to take
on a new adventure involving goblins again.
And if you want to join us
on our next Goblin Hunt,
Don't forget to like, comment, subscribe and
check out the How to Beat playlist down below.